what's up you beautiful rejects just wanted
to let you all know that we are coming to
WonderCon Greg Coy and myself live Sunday
March the 26th 11 A.M to noon come join us
for a discussion about the current state of
the MCU and DCU fandom should be a blast now
let's just jump into it how's it going citizens
of the reject Nation we are back for yet another
movie reaction first time watching and with
me in the hot seat once again it's the ever
unpredictable Roxy strier how you doing Roxy
when you watch back this video you will see
that we opened with me trying to fist bump
you and you left me so hanging you just wanted
to hang out with the citizens of rejection
which I understand so concerned with them
but I was just like this and so everybody
at home all the fist bumps yeah there you
go we are here to watch Ip Man people don't
know much of anything about this movie other
than it is at least some iteration of the
story of the master who trained Bruce Lee
very excited to check this out and as always
before we hop into this do all the regular
things leave a like on the video subscribe
to the channel hit the notification Bell and
be sure to follow Roxy on social media as
well as the world girls how are the world
girls doing we're whirling whirling and twirling
that's good for a martial arts movie as always
if you want to see The Full Experience alongside
us uh everything that doesn't make the reaction
highlights come on over to patreon.com real
reject subscribe over there sync up with your
own copy cannot show you the full movie unfortunately
but hey it's a fun time just the same as well
thank you to prepper for editing down these
highlights Roxy are you ready to throw down
the year the year is 2008. I'm in high school
it it comes out
clearly not because it's 2023 now but let's
hop into this
foreign
[Music] excited
[Music] [Applause] martial arts got his whole
own Street yeah martial arts street okay
start practicing all on top of each other
much be rather flying a kite than having a
fight
[Music]
yeah you just showed up out of nowhere
foreign
immediately starving I know this looks so
good I want
she might be the most stunning person I've
ever seen in my life dude you've tried to
play it down but it's just live Your Truth
All Right Live Your Truth Roxanne
you can't catch something that's unattached
yep
that
fly back you got the best seat in the house
dude
oh
like he says here I come but he stays still
[Music]
wow
that was very endearing actually though yeah
I'm sorry oh it's okay buddy dust yourself
off
oh he's gonna think that he told them yeah
[Music] oh hey I don't know kick his butt
um
yeah there you go go take it up with him oh
he probably thinks that Master EP told this
kid though
[Music]
um
foreign dang that's a debate yeah whoa pick
up pants he I did not expect a pantsing no
yeah
but Justin yes we know all cops are Justice
oh a stare whoa whoa
how do you
do that [Applause] gun must not have been
assembled that well
sad I know yeah
yeah get out of your heads up
[Music] couldn't be too nice foreign
I love her this is a lovely Garden yeah
should we move in we can afford this is
martial arts are taking over your life I wouldn't
say she threw a tantrum about it I mean that
was pretty hysterical all right I don't know
what you call it just lose her mind check
her into the institution
oh good another great set yeah
oh he knows
whoa no ah whoa that KIPP up down that was
crazy oh
in his legs oh
thump
how frequently does this happen on the street
I don't know this must happen all the time
but the guy did accept his challenge you have
to accept anybody's challenge what are the
rules oh
so you get one of those and they don't I mean
it seem fair nah his dudes got that big ass
damn the sound design too
oh
Punk
that
was really good yeah that's some of the best
fighting I've ever seen in my life John
fella
it seems like such a sweet guy oh you're just
saying that because he's always smiling
what does it mean to beat the master though
do you get to school or you just embarrass
them I think yeah it's mostly just your your
embarrassing them and then their students
are going to have doubts about them
ah God you really feel those impacts man
no no no no no oh nice oh damn it how are
they doing this please oh no
they're all martial artists right like this
isn't stunned people I mean both it's probably
like a bunch of stunt teams
job's not done [Laughter] can't eat until
we've beaten the best it feels like a musical
a little bit I love it like Kung Fu West sides
yeah oh shoot yeah
plenty of uh want ads he comes into his home
plenty of classifieds
kick this guy's ass honey I'm with her don't
break these things they're so nice
foreign [Music] what's your BET right now
why you think IP is going to lose and then
go on some kind of like massive Revenge but
I feel like if it's gonna beat this guy's
ass right now we just have quite some time
left in the movie but I can't picture him
losing
good
he's playing defense though oh yeah don't
break damn it man you had one job
the wife probably heard the crash and I was
like oh yeah
damn it that's what I'm betting on I'm betting
that this whole place gets right ah damn it
kiddo
ORS [Music] this is the cutest oh dude now
you've done it brat don't talk about the sun
I don't spend time with
wow her work in this movie too is there a
word for people who hate kids yeah can you
be a Phyllis sanderist or something or I don't
know what sounds those were that just came
out of my mouth right there but uh the actual
word is a mesopotist one who hates children
isn't it man great though let's get back to
it man
oh like a brick jeez wow
wow [Music] oh that's so unfair right no this
is regulation oh nah this dude's desperate
this is so dope yes such a great touch
uh give him a spanking
foreign
[Music]
you see them
oh damn
oh no and still it just kept trading is this
about to be a World War II movie very well
could be we got a couple more years still
but this just said Japan invaded China China
invaded Japan
[Music] wow
[Music] wow is this true I think this aspect
must be true all right oh no no
homeless and for solution wow
doesn't mean
she is such a natural way about her yeah [Music]
oh no so you're gonna start up a school so
they can fight back maybe maybe that's how
they'll make a living now [Music] oh what
a contrast yeah that was like the contrast
from the the first part of the movie to now
is almost like parasite it's like a different
genre yeah whoa
and the feathers yeah good catch what a different
time
that's the least you can do after you set
you up foreign
no don't [__] with my girl
is
gonna go work at that Mill right now
this got so sad so fast like life I suppose
what oh damn is his name still carries weight
yeah well I'm a little surprised he accepted
despite all those other people in need but
yeah that did seem not in his character but
his wife needs it so yeah
just the color contrast with the food
oh oh
yeah
oh buddy he's out chasing a kite somewhere
that was such a beautiful moment when he gave
him that
oh I was in the box I don't know is that about
to be a big problem seemed like it now that
the Japanese are here what a moment that was
though yeah
um
foreign [Laughter] [Music]
just keep on asking bud no one wants to be
a traitor he'll get it eventually
um
yes yes
it is
foreign
[Music]
box though
oh
oh ho ho ho ho what is it for their entertainment
or something partially probably Gaga but also
yeah I guess probably to break the faith that
they could fight back at all
okay okay oh
yes you are just Gladiators then
this is so interesting
damn still keep your pants in your belt so
it's not as dark as I thought it was where
they were like fighting to the death or something
oh whoa [Laughter] color in this movie is
fascinating yeah because we are in a black
and white scene right now right full blown
either black or white or just like incredibly
desaturated yeah
oh
Jesus dude
these shots okay so maybe it is as dark as
I thought it was
oh [Music] wow
nope
he's gotta find that 10.
this has so much Poise yeah he's like a true
star yeah
[Laughter]
I do not like that guy yeah he's doing he
has to do to survive but he's a traitor yeah
bringing people where he knows that they're
getting so hurt did his best not to bring
up but yeah
or learn how to do that yeah
[Music] you gotta get up
to fight dirty I just let him be done
what it's why
this is why you're not the head guy
yeah was he I mean that's the strong implication
he didn't look like he was going to walk away
from that last fight I mean that active Defiance
spitting in the General's face pretty much
sealed it you know [Music] I feel like he's
gonna run the whole line
yes
you do get to talk right now dude yeah you
calm down you're lucky to be here right now
I hate him
oh damn
oh
wow wow [Music]
Christ
they're all
coming at him one at a time I know there we
go yeah they were like people are gonna start
to wonder
[Music]
oh
we've never seen a fight like that oh not
with Fury
yeah yep yep
if he picks it up you're gonna shoot him
take the rice so you can give it to people
hahaha yep no more this
we have a title video [Music] because you
are good next video no you're not everybody
has to do
you crush him right now your dignity bro I
can't stand you you're the worst kind of person
you are a traitor
ha ha second means
yeah clean yourself up for the potato I understand
I just have to wash your face she seemed pretty
clean to me this guy I was hoping you'd make
a return yeah
oh these dudes like marauding oh that's a
brother kite boy
there you go
I was cool even they came back so in the truck
was it a bunch of Japanese soldiers I don't
know if it was a soldier truck but it seemed
like it was a Japanese truck okay yeah I think
at the moment I thought this was going to
be some kind of Robin Hood face turn for them
but uh no they're just robbing folks from
Foshan from folks from the mill so uh you
know there you go
Cinema
oh yeah
oh damn you Northern guy rematch
I'll get there get there yeah it's a necessity
the school right here
laughs
long last
come join Master IPS School of kung fu oh
[Music] my hands becoming a part of the community
training montage sequence commence yeah
[Music]
even family life is better now foreign
dude someone needs to desk this guy or relieve
him of Duty entirely
Teach Me How to Dougie [Music] oh no
no why did she make noise just that I don't
know no no no no no no no no no no no
oh yes yes this is gonna be bad for you but
yes they all have guns oh my gosh yes hey
guns don't mean [__] right now
yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Music] Rubino Hong Kong
um Asgard as a people oh this guy comes back
no you I mean you're either with us or you're
against us you got to team up the enemy of
your enemy is your friend you need to be our
friend right now you cannot be causing this
kind of ish you're not helping you're not
helping anybody's cause
oh yeah
sharks in a jet stuff
yes let's go how much are you guys foreign
okay this is the least realistic part but
I'm still really into it they all learned
how to fight like gangsters in a day you know
they're taking some hits oh yup defend yourself
oh let's go let's do it but if you're supposed
to be in hiding honey it's okay he can't stay
hid when there's Injustice afoot I love it
is the best character
no we didn't you ruined this because
oh and I've been hungry every day since oh
Jesus don't do it you're in fighting none
of you guys are the problem oh boy
let's go
sugar come on dude
he's got the ultimate rage one and he didn't
know his brother's dead
I'm pretty good with the bow stuff [Music]
nicely done and that must have been a nice
soft Landing
[Music]
do you think he ever opened it knowing him
probably not right probably not yeah I would
say it would respect the integrity
oh no what is it it's the kite oh oh it's
his kite oh
buddy
nah he's gonna go straight there [Music]
'd be right because it's gonna protect the
people right yeah he's just gonna go have
it out once and for all foreign
[Music]
nope
yeah dude let's go let's go
wow
so it's a guitar oh baby
no you didn't honey that was not a tantrum
yes you did babe it was
a different time you did yeah so much yeah
you both he could have showed up for the kid
more before you need a little you couldn't
realize yeah it's okay you both have a character
arcade
come down
[Laughter]
all right what do you think it's gonna lose
and everyone's just gonna be subject to that
much more tyranny don't say that
um
[Music] well we got it we understand foreign
wow
damn dude nice use of Leverage
I am so invested right now yeah breathless
oh I would so love it if you just got knocked
out of bounds and they were like good the
Japanese win yeah
yes yes
oh don't shoot him come on don't shoot him
punch him
oh oh no what she went there why why'd she
go
going right Back to Basics I feel like they're
gonna shoot him [Music]
he saw the guy reaching for his gun
surrender
[Music] [Applause]
oh no I'm nervous no no no no oh
damn it this guy someone needs to smack the
[__] out of that guy
that's a pretty high wound you can get the
best singing that but yep that's all we needed
kill him come on dude yep come on
[Music]
yeah oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy [Music] oh
God this is not a good way to save somebody's
life yeah you're gonna crush him is anybody
a doctor
foreign [Music]
[Music]
oh no way my man all right okay all right
okay okay wow [Music] oh wow [Music]
strange question mark hey you sure about that
subtitles yeah
I could see why you want to learn from him
that was truly unbelievable God what a movie
so what do you make of how much of that do
you think is true real I was just wondering
that yeah I have I mean the timeline and the
history aspect of it feels very real I'm curious
about the actual Ip Man of it all yeah me
too because I've heard you know in hearing
about this movie over the years people have
often gone out of their way to be like yeah
it's the story of Bruce Lee's Master like
you know it's it's embellished a lot uh but
yeah it's it's based on that true story and
and here watching this this felt more grounded
and more historical than I was expecting like
I came in expecting a lot of crazy ass fights
and stuff like that and the fights are amazing
but like I expected almost every fight just
from hearing about it over the years to be
like yeah 10 people at a time like that one
uh and it's not exactly that so I would be
fascinated to see and I don't have the best
you know historical knowledge of this period
this conflict Etc this part of the world but
uh that's the that's the part that's crazy
because it says you know August 1945 so obviously
we know that I obviously World War II is near
and dear to my heart as my family comes from
Eastern Europe and is Jewish so but I think
about it on that front I am so ignorant when
it comes to um I know more a little bit about
the Japanese front but not with regards to
China yeah absolutely you can kind of look
like look watching this and knowing the dates
and no having a little bit of an understanding
of the world but being like what happened
there yeah that is actually a big blind spot
for me um you know we think about Japan in
regards to the United States we don't think
about Japan in regards to um wherever in China
that you know they said from 300 000 people
to 70 000 people and it's like what I don't
even know that story yeah absolutely and then
it makes me wonder then I'm like okay so what
was our relation to China then during all
of this because again in America you you have
Pearl Harbor you have all those right with
Japan yeah you have the very Vivid Japanese
American conflict right but what was our yeah
relation to China during the time if any at
all really yeah you think enemy of your enemy
is your friend but also I think more we were
fighting on the Eastern European front sure
yeah just that's a big blind spot so it was
it almost made it more enticing of a movie
because I genuinely was like what is that
what's gonna happen here yeah 100 like I really
enjoyed that that historic it's it's weird
because it does put you I feel like oftentimes
when you figure out like okay this is a true
story this is based on history so you feel
like it won't like I feel like in in some
cases that will ground you and make you sort
of less expecting of the unexpected whereas
here I was like man this is like a situation
I I knew this is expanding my pre-existing
knowledge on World War II and just the time
leading up to World War II and things like
that like I was completely unaware that it
man was I guess at this point do we call it
this is a World War II movie right yeah I
mean it's historical fiction I mean it encompasses
it takes place during that time yeah that
time and then up until you know slightly I
mean you know the epilogue gives you the information
as to what happened slightly after but but
yeah this is a highly skilled fighter sets
out to defend his people amid simmering tensions
and brutal conditions in China under Japanese
Occupation so I I just knew of this as a fighting
movie I knew of this as like an action-packed
but the whole historical relevance of it was
really just next level elevated it but then
completely apart from that the the story is
so beautiful yeah the story of him and his
family the story of him helping his people
the story of even when you have nothing giving
everything you have to your loved ones I loved
that yeah and like I I really loved how grounded
a lot of this was because again I went in
expecting something a little more mystical
a little more stylized whereas this felt like
it was just as dedicated to living in the
time and place that it was depicting and living
in just the people's lives of the day and
I loved how it took you from you know and
and you know like in fitting with movie structure
you take us from the status quo like everything's
great everything's at least you know you have
this conflict with this guy from the north
coming into town trying to prove himself but
you see the status quo of just what flourishing
life is like uh in what is it called Foshan
and then you know watching then the huge contrast
descend as you know the Japanese invade uh
yeah I just made everything like way more
tangible and way more affecting than I was
expecting and so it it made me want to go
out and like learn more about the history
but I also just found myself appreciating
yeah like like we were both pointing out you
were especially were pointing out like the
set designs are beautiful it's so well crafted
and realized and caringly recreated you know
yeah so incredible and I'm with you I did
think that this was almost gonna be more like
just bigger and more Fantastical kind of and
it in some moments it is there are some moments
where it's like you know uh just so wild like
everybody in the street or like we're all
coming to your house and we're coming inside
and it feels like I said at times it feels
like a musical like a West Side Story but
really it's hard at its core it was so grounded
which is kind of bizarre not what I was expecting
from this and it does make me want to go do
more research which you know is a sign of
a good movie when you're immediately like
I've got to start googling because I need
no to know more about Ip Man I need to know
more about this time period in this location
uh yeah and the infighting part was so interesting
that they that they have that in this where
it's not just the Japanese Occupation of this
area of China it is the uh it is Chinese people
and Chinese people fighting with each other
because they don't want to be bullied like
as they said that and if that obviously resonates
with this country right now I forget which
stand-up comedian I was talking uh not talking
to I was listening to the other day it might
have been in Chris Rock special where he was
talking about you know half the people right
now if Russia came here half the people would
be like let's hear them out because we there's
so much infighting in the United States where
we're not even on the same page and it's like
you would like to think everybody joins together
in a time of War but in this time of War I
thought what was going to happen is that once
we the the Japanese Occupation comes we both
thought like oh they're coming back and they're
coming to help and they're not coming to help
they're coming to harm and it's like whoa
that is realistic but also gut-wrenching yeah
you came back and then you came for your own
people oh that was uh great the theatrical
choice but brutal yeah and I wonder how that
moment would play if if you are familiar with
both Japanese and China because when he comes
into the into the road there and he stops
the truck I think yeah it creates this idea
of like oh man he's about to throw a wrench
in their system but you know you you see at
least one brief shot of the people in the
truck and you're like does this look like
two regular people though I wonder and then
yeah yeah and and it goes by quick enough
that you're still just sort of charged up
like that's the thing is this movie has the
emotional impact that makes you like charged
up like it has the emotional experience that
I think I was expecting going in but yeah
with like way more grounded and interesting
circumstances so that yeah when he comes back
to town with the brother it is like a greater
part and it's a part of the conflict that
I'm glad they touched upon because I feel
like in any culture this is liable to happen
you'll have your people who are under the
thumb of the Tyranny you'll have your people
who are trying to fight back in some way and
then you'll have your people on the margins
who are doing their own program trying to
scavenge and survive and you know really every
man for themselving basically and then there's
people who go into those classifications at
a different time like we saw with Trader yeah
Trader was at first in one of those genres
and then was like or in one of those groups
and then was like I cannot betray my people
like this even if it kills me and I can't
really delude myself into thinking that I'm
somehow helping to ease tensions between us
I'm a translator I'm a translator you're still
helping their operation more than you're helping
you know yeah until he wasn't that was so
every character served a purpose too like
the the nephew and the son the wife um the
guy that borrowed money from him the brother
and the guy with the kite and his brother
just there were so many characters that I
cared about and we wanted to see what ended
up at the trader uh the general of the Japanese
Army's right hand man who we hated who was
even a bigger villain than the general himself
because you couldn't trust him there's just
so many people in this that I was like I am
curious what happens with you your character
is so developed in my mind even though they
might not have spent that much time with you
yeah I am shocked with how much I love this
yeah and it unfolds in a really natural way
that doesn't feel overly contrived like part
of me again they get to the whole Like Gladiator
you know they're they're all barred up and
they're going on to the mat and fighting for
rice and I was like part way through like
okay so here's where all the the shit's gonna
go down but no not not even really like we
check out of there for a good long time and
and we just feel yeah the time and the geography
and the life of the situation and I love the
way that yeah you you just like I it's one
of those movies where the pacing feels so
natural that you're never really thinking
of the mechanics of what the pace is doing
and why certain moments are where so it creates
this really natural blossoming from or I guess
wilting out of yeah you know the again status
quo of life and and seeing Ip Man as he was
then so poised always gentle and smiling you
know certainly willing to you know engage
in a duel or whatever but a guy who is not
initiating yeah and then seeing how that adjusts
itself how that Poise adjusts to the descent
into the Tyranny and and seeing how he still
has so many of those same you know core tenets
of his character even though they're slightly
different because of the circumstances he
is still kind of giving off that same impression
it's so much about how he carries himself
and holds himself and that creates this really
great Mystique around him in a way even though
he does just feel like I'm like a man and
then everybody else around him feels that
much more human as a result and and like I
think it's good that the movie
it's like it would have been more of a movie
choice to have that one right-hand man you
know I wanted to see him get his ass beat
you know at the end after after shooting him
and all that stuff uh but it's not exactly
that kind of movie and that's okay you know
yeah you know that the First Act or however
long that was where we just from the start
of the movie to the point where he beats the
bot of the guy who uh comes in to start his
own School in his house yeah I had turned
to you and I said what do you think's gonna
happen here because I thought that was the
villain of the movie yeah it was gonna be
the whole movie you know so I'm like okay
so maybe they have to draw or he has to lose
because we got to fight this guy again at
some point thinking that that's the whole
movie and had that been the movie had that
been the theme of the movie had we not had
all any of the other developments yeah doing
schools in the streets and who gets to have
the schools there and what matters in terms
of can you still have a teacher who who isn't
the most powerful can they still teach whatever
I thought that that's kind of the themes we're
going with and I was thinking to myself okay
I'm down for this ride yeah like it wasn't
like I was sitting there thinking oh I'm bored
this is whatever but then the movie decided
to be so much more than that it decided to
then be like oh you thought you knew what
this movie is you don't you don't know what
life is because you know what's around the
corner an occupation yeah that you can't like
action movie hero your way out of you did
not see this coming because nobody sees War
coming like this like exactly and it just
it hit both of us we kind of turned to each
other and we're like
[__] just got real yeah really real yeah
and the colors changed and the atmosphere
changed the prop everything just looked so
different as it would during wartime and then
I turned to you he said what was the year
on that just thinking like oh my God we're
we're in on in this planet yeah like this
is we're in history yeah yeah we're in history
yeah that was just such a great job of I don't
think that they were trying to trick us but
of starting with one thing that would have
been a good movie solid but then turning it
into a great movie by being like this there's
so much more going on here yeah that's the
fun part about watching something like this
a little after a lot of people and and not
coming in having seen like a trailer and all
sorts of other stuff is yeah you have a couple
Notions of what you might expect you probably
know Donnie Yen and then yeah it really this
was you know what I love so much about various
cinematic experiences and especially ones
like this and I love too that like I have
more experience when it comes to you know
historical operatic Chinese Cinema stuff you
know like like your obvious things like a
Crouching Tiger or hero or House of Flying
Daggers or something like that and this has
less of the Fantastical operatic side of that
but it does have that you know traditional
history mixed with just dramatic Cinema like
it it has all the action it is an action movie
but it really feels like a historical drama
that just so happens to center around people
who practice and communicate via in certain
situations the martial arts yeah I would say
that the strongest part of this film is the
story Idaho isn't it isn't that crazy like
you would think that when we were seeing the
costume design and everything I'm sitting
there thinking of course the strongest part
is going to be the martial arts and then it's
going to be the design of it all but the strongest
part to me and this is no knock on anything
else no is the story yeah no it's like it's
a it's like in the best way possible that's
an awesome surprise because if the story is
good that only makes the action that much
better and that only makes it more of a complete
and well-rounded film and and even other things
like I love being able to sit through a movie
like this and be like wow like what interesting
choices of the color grading and you know
the way they've chosen to frame certain things
and it's like it's got a lot of very lovely
and and striking and deliberate imagery throughout
and harsh imagery especially throughout um
but really harsh and the flashes of some really
harsh imagery yeah and like the way they draw
those contrasts and the way they highlight
you know it's like it man you could argue
like you know he is so poised and in so many
situations you're like well he's he's got
this but it's all the other intonation of
of emotion that they put both on his character
through the visual storytelling but also just
through the greater tapestry of all the other
characters around that really create something
that feels still rich and emotionally alive
you know even though yeah I mean he is it's
about him kind of learning his place it feels
like in this greater than life conflict and
learning how to apply skills yeah his value
his skills and yeah the value like the True
Values and tenets of what the martial artist
for and how he might be able to yeah Inspire
and empower the people around him not just
as a teacher for the clout of a school like
we see at the beginning but like for the the
real reason these Arts exist it's like you
know you gotta imagine they always say like
you know you learn this stuff for defense
you don't want to have to use it whereas you
know he finds a situation in which no these
people need this yeah yeah the lesson in that
also being that it teaches you principles
that you apply in life such as in life you
do what you have to do so as he turns to his
wife and says I haven't had to work now I
do so I'm gonna do that and and the humility
that it takes to know that you went from being
this Rich well-known in your town respected
guy to shoveling coal and he doesn't seem
to have any judgment on that situation that's
negative he just knows in life I I don't want
to fight I don't I'm not looking to fight
I don't want to have to shovel coal but you
have to do what you have to do based on the
cards that you're dealt and therefore I'm
going to do that so he is able to apply those
lessons outside of martial arts and then teach
other people to apply those lessons which
is really cool and then the other thing that
I will say about this that I thought was interesting
and I know that I get knocked on this all
of the time from my friends my family and
from people on the internet which I completely
get because it makes me sound so ignorant
is that I have a hard time with foreign language
films because I am partially dyslexic and
it takes me a really long time to read things
and so oftentimes I go dubs not Subs which
I know people I know when I tell people that
it honestly they treat me like I I murdered
their firstborn like they they people hate
that and I get it it is a character flaw and
I and I understand why because as an artist
it is uh disrespectful at times to not be
able to pay attention to the the original
art and um I really do try recently I'm really
trying to train myself you know if you have
to pause you have to pause whatever but I
was so invested in this story that I really
forgot that I was reading yeah it was like
just going there it was not over dialogue
heavy which was helpful uh it was more in
like their the facial expressions and the
moments and whatever but for me somebody who
does struggle foreign language films it to
love it to this extent is even just more credit
to this movie that it was like just it was
a cakewalk in terms of the subtitles that
was that I hope that it doesn't deter anybody
because it was so well done yeah absolutely
it it yeah it like the the there's good uh
you know I'd say it's a well-written movie
there's good dialogue throughout but it is
one of those movies that's also very well
visually told so yeah it's like there isn't
a lot of laborious dialogue that you gotta
really keep up with to understand like an
exposition stuff can get really hard when
it's yeah like remember last Tuesday when
you called my uncle and I'm like I've lost
the this yeah yeah give me little alert chunks
please sure sure and this is the perfect blend
of of yeah like there is context and there
is certainly you know certain stuff that you
can only get out via dialogue but there's
so much of this that is so very Universal
and clear through yeah just bolstered by those
visuals and bolstered by just the emotional
again the subtle emotionality of the filmmaking
on display in general because yeah if they
can get you to that place where you're not
even thinking about it that's that's the ideal
and they really did they really did I was
able to turn that nervous part of my brain
off like am I going to be able to keep up
and really just enjoy the ride yeah that was
so good so good and I it makes me wonder like
how on Earth do you turn this into a franchise
see if there's that two and three I think
there's it man four I think there's a lot
of it man's so I'm like they must at some
point like Ascend into a certain level of
fantasy or or you know I don't know being
good do we know I think it's a well-liked
series overall I mean I think I I don't my
guess from the outside is I would be surprised
if they are able to maintain all of the um
you know coalescing genres that make this
movie what it is right I I I guess me I would
expect for the sequels to increasingly lean
into the Mystique and you know the crazier
and crazier fights and things like that but
I don't know I I don't like you see the epilogue
you know and they tell you sort of the the
wrap-up history of how he goes on to start
his school and then you know train all these
people and that has to be truly right yeah
and I mean like that's my main Association
up until now was like oh it's it's Loosely
based on the guy who who trained and inspired
Bruce Lee um so so having that in mind you
like I feel like there's plenty of room for
them to to get bigger in terms of fantasy
but yeah just thinking about those moments
I was like so are they gonna did they leave
anything out that will lend themselves to
a sequel story because it seems like he just
kind of went on and lived his life and opened
his school and realized that new aspect of
the dream in Hong Kong Etc um yeah everything
else feels like it's probably not as grounded
in the truth yeah so I'm gonna go off with
the character and yeah they didn't know how
big the franchise was gonna be is it man too
just gonna tell the story of you know it's
the 60s and he's running a school like I don't
know yeah I'm not sure about that either it
is rated R are you surprised by that or because
of the violence you think that that makes
sense I'm not surprised it's not the hardest
R I've ever seen but it is one I think that
deliberately uses the harshness of again wartime
and at least a there are enough really pointed
blood gags and and you know like when that
one guy gets shot in the you know sparring
Dojo like that's pretty harsh the bloody rice
yeah so it's one of those things where I wasn't
thinking at all about the rating but I'm not
surprised it's rated R uh because yeah yeah
I mean it's getting into pretty harsh territory
and there is just like you know people can
hit a lot a lot a lot a lot and even though
it's not the bloodiest movie ever you know
you've seen bones breaking you're seeing a
fair amount of blood when it's appropriate
so yeah I I feel I feel the r on this and
I feel like that substantiates some of that
historical drama too you know what this is
gonna end up being like a movie that I tell
people if have you not seen this you have
to go watch it you know I can just tell immediately
while I was watching it in my head I was thinking
I got to tell my friends yeah and I'm sure
most of them yeah it came out over a decade
ago I've seen it rocks but this is one of
those things where I feel late to the party
and I need to make sure that nobody else is
misses the party yeah no 100 it's one of those
movies where it's I have that same inclination
I'm like oh I gotta go talk about this as
many people as possible or tell people to
see it and it's so cool because again like
it's not John Wick and I love a John Wick
movie I'm excited for Donnie Anne to be in
John Wick 4 but like this is like such a film
and it is so again it has all that badass
you know fist pump being stuff that you want
and but it's not as Fantastical even as like
a Crouching Tiger and yet it's not just that
fist pump movie either like it's it's kind
of a nice niche for this uh kind of Cinema
to me where I feel like you know if you've
seen a lot of the biggest crossover hits that
have come to America but you haven't seen
this this might you know fill in a part of
the spectrum for you as it did me in a fun
way yeah I'm so with you that one scene where
they come to him and his wife is standing
over in the the gun with the kid that's so
chilling and that guy's pointing like a real
gun on his child like that's what the R-rated
kind of stuff but that is that was such a
crazy scene and also just so when he as he
had been questioning is my martial arts worth
it like that do I have any value you just
protected and saved the lives of your kid
and your wife you have more value than anybody
could possibly have you know like you saw
what was gonna happen there it was not about
clout or anything like that like I did love
you know again it gives you so many threads
to to think it'll follow and yeah at the beginning
with that other master and I was like oh here
we go you know um but even seeing the way
that that evolved and letting every character
really feel like an alive actual character
you see that guy later on and he's holding
his own he tries to fight three guys and it
doesn't go well but he's holding his own yeah
you know like there's so many nice little
living earmarks and elements they threw in
his like yeah this is fantastic that's so
good so good when we open it's all the flags
and I was thinking that's a lot of flags but
I didn't wasn't thinking it's because they're
about to be replaced as they're going to be
occupied you know like they have so much um
nationalism and so much uh like pride in their
country and then when you just see how built
up and how how sort of bustling and it at
least seems very flourishing at the top where
where it's you know it's right it's in the
30s but it still has that kind of not cyberpunk
but you know like you're used to cutting to
like a city in China or Japan it's like Signs
On signs on signs on advertisements and like
there is that kind of flourishing Cultural
Center uh quality and the amazing food and
we're seeing like all about their culture
in their in their um homes and their food
and their businesses and their flags and their
every in their um the martial arts like it's
it was so true to their culture and then and
to the spirit of martial arts in general yeah
yeah yeah and then to be have that taken over
in such a short period of time we I felt like
I knew how um I I knew how these people lived
and then it was like now you don't live like
this anymore well yeah and then and then yeah
it's like barbed wire and and you know like
big Japanese you know kanji characters painted
up all over the place and it's just it feels
like it's been completely transformed in such
a harsh way and and and yeah it's like the
movie I feel like overall does like a really
cool job of embodying the spirit of and the
reasoning behind martial arts like that debate
that it man kind of faces throughout about
how and why to use it and going from these
scenarios where it's like ah it's kind of
fun you know it's like for the clout of these
different schools and then going to you know
like really finding the true the core the
deepest reason to you know to take a stand
and to act it's really beautiful yeah I'm
so with you wow yep yep a plus a plus that
was like a 9.5 out of 10 for me absolutely
not gonna go full 10. honestly I'm trying
to think what could have made it better and
I don't I I genuinely don't know I just don't
know if I've ever said anything as a 10. that
was as good as movies gets for me if that
one guy had an extended sequence where they
just like beat the [__] out of him then
it would have been totally totally yeah all
right all right you got any stray thoughts
before we hit the road I guess it's time to
see it man too it man two let us know in the
comments if you want to see it man too if
you want to see any other uh badass and or
super affecting martial arts joints you might
want to see us check out you know comment
below like subscribe all that good stuff follow
Roxy stryer follow the world girls and last
but not least let's do a patreon
Chris Wham off Chris you are the IP man of
the patreon yeah no Chris is great Chris is
always poised Chris is always out there helping
the people but never asking for too much he
doesn't want to be in people's debt and he
doesn't even care to have people indebted
to him but he's always out there helping out
wham bam thank you man if man wham bam thank
you it bam yeah there you go you should create
your own martial arts style though that's
what I would want to see if you had to tussle
if you had to throw Hands Chris what would
your approach be what would be your Technique
I want to know something leaning in with the
pinkies yeah even the pinky can be Kung Fu
like uh like everything everywhere yeah yeah
that's good I like it well Chris be well uh
maintain your pledge that's all we ask here
uh otherwise we'll come over there we'll jump
you for Honor yeah exactly JK never pick fight
with Chris I never pick a fight with Chris
because even if you physically win morally
he will defeat you 12 times over we saw that
happen in it man we did that's why you are
the IP man of the patreon be well my dude
foreign